The Story Goes that the first temple to
stand at the site in the image was built
by a race of little people known as the
menahune
then we needed to
thousands of them and it took one night
according to Legend
studies suggest that in the 12th century
the temple is rebuilt and its walls
heightened to 30 feet
it is dedicated to the god coup
a deity who shapeshifts between human
and shark form and is known as the Eater
of islands he is a particularly fearsome
God he's the God of War who was probably
the most important of these Hawaiian
gods and only the king the priesthood
and the highest nobles were allowed
access to the temple